okay so you're now coming on after these
two films that John Lasseter has
directed yes he's executive producer and
yes he's very involved but he chose you
to direct in you to produce so what was
that legacy wait like there's no wait
when I'm talking we talking about I
volunteered another six years ago I'm
like what was I thinking she's six years
how did how did was it something he said
I want you to come up with a project or
did so I was working on I was working on
it as had a story in development we had
the crafting of the the early part of
what this became which was a mentorship
story right that was always there at the
present that was the thing that was most
interesting to us really moving by to me
it's very personal and what I got a I
got tapped on the shoulder
Darrin one day at work and said John
last wants to see you right now so so I
walked those off that could be good or
bad you know I
so in yeah John said I want you to
direct this movie I think I screamed
inside my head for spit-up and I had
never directed anything before so I
don't know their direct a movie was a
story artist so you know storytelling is
my background but there's a lot more to
putting that on the screen there's a lot
of there's a lot of more things to come
through but but I had the support of the
studio I had support of John so it was
never a question do I want to it was the
quit we'll figure it out I'll figure out
how to direct the movie but I wanted to
tell the story what were the biggest
challenges that you had jumping into the
director's chair and you jump in the
producers chair I had to learn
communication because there's a story
artists to kind of work in a very small
group usually by yourself in an office
you know thinking of working up the
scene you know you draw we draw
everything many many many times you know
before it ever we ever get this far just
to figure out the story it's the
leadership of that you know that was new
to me I had to learn how to communicate
and how to do it efficiently so that can
inspire you know every of the best work
out of everybody for me probably biggest
challenge was they came to us
said we've got good news and bad news
the good news is we love your movie the
bad news is we're taking a year out of
your schedule and and so all of a sudden
we went to becoming summer of seventeen
and and that was a little daunting we
had a team of 30 and in two weeks we had
150 the first week we were there we are
announced on a Tuesday and on Thursday
we had a lego meeting where they said
we'll just give us all your model
packets of your characters we like we
don't have any model packets we don't
have any characters we don't have an art
department so you know is that good that
was pretty daunting had you finished the
script or was there were innocent script
we're never all the time we're never
finished it still tada you have been
forming it now we're never finished with
that we will change things anything we
can do to make the movie better we will
do it up until we physically can't do it
anymore we were done with that with the
end race sequence it was animated wasn't
lit yet you know we ever worked that far
down but picture was locked animation
was done on it Randy was in the middle
of writing the score actors were gone
and and so Mike rich writer who hadn't
been on the film for a year he we sent
him a copy just so he could see what we
did yeah like I said he was on it for a
year things are going to change and he
had a note for us and it was it's in
that situation where it's like a little
late for a note but he always sees a
smart guy and so he gave us a note that
we were really missing a moment we're
cruising MacLean really thank each other
for for what they've done for each other
you know after the race and he was right
that was that was a wonderful note so we
did it we did it without dialogue which
to me is my fav now for my favorite
movie in the movie but we had to stop
you know go back in animation we got to
shoot some more shots we got to figure
this out call Randy on the phone you
know expect a new picture change
we haven't locked it yet that there's
going to be a moment here and it's
actually really important so everything
you're doing with the score actually
needs to build at that moment and he
knocked it out what were some of the
challenges in trying to bring the film
up to date and yet at the same time have
it be still a cars world that we're used
to mud mud was really hard ten years ago
we couldn't have done that you know
kalapa mud dried mud caked mud
you've got water click now and so
exactly water water and smoke and fire
we got all that lick now it's mud well
there's a little crystal you know very
variations on all those things you we we
had to everything had to come back from
scratch again so all the characters all
the sets we had to remake the technology
has changed and we and we're going to
make it look better because we can we
can do things we couldn't do that we
would love to hand it look like that you
know 10 11 years ago but so we wanted it
to look as good as we possibly could
because we didn't want it to look aged
we don't look we don't want this maybe
the clay came out 2006 so when it could
be the world you remember but through a
better pair of glasses and so we all the
modeling everything is it shaders
everything about it was was kicked up a
notch and the renderer that we have now
is what's responsible for the the level
of realism we can achieve and with this
movie we wanted to lean in to you know
really nin to realism as much as
possible because we want you to be able
to smell the air you know we want you to
feel the dust we want we want the
atmosphere to you know feel humidity
you know just anything we can do to have
the audience feel like they're actually
in that set and also because the realism
is kicked up we are looking at our
models we had to stiffen things up or we
our first animation was coming back in
the end you know animators live they
love to get really crazy and bounce
these things around but they're you know
the way we're rendering now they're that
they look even more like real cars and
that you know 4,000 pounds needs to look
like it's 4,000 pounds so we had to find
we'd to tweak our animation style and
kind of find a whole new approach that
was inspired by you know what had been
done earlier but kind of our own thing
because this is our own thing you say
were originally inspired by the
mentorship story what where did that
emanate from and why was that so
important there's I think there's
probably two sides to that there's a
plot and then there's a motion a plot
wise we were looking at where McQueen is
now as a racer he's no longer the
hotshot racer so where would be in his
career and we talked a lot with Jeff
Gordon and you know Jeff chorus he was
getting close to time too
and he would told us the thing that he
feared the most what he would never be
good at anything else ever again
so that's kind of where we were looking
around plot-wise that's just the surface
level right the emotion is is that the
thing we're always really chasing and I
had this experience with my daughter's I
wanted to show them that there's no
different than their little crayon
drawings that they could do at school
and like a real finished nice painted
illustration professionally done that
there's it's still a person holding a
stick you know the only difference is
that professional person spent more time
on it and had done more of them in their
lifetime so I have an illustration
background and so I was going to just
give them a little lesson I set up one
of my daughter's American Girl dolls and
I'm going to do a painting demonstration
I'm going to paint its portrait you know
when I draw it out and let's see first
yeah you draw out just get the rough
shapes and you look at the light you try
to available they're too young to care
and 20 minutes later they just walked
away they're bored they're going to play
but I'm going to stick to this so I'm
going to show I'm going to show them the
final product they could probably spent
three hours on it and then I showed it
to him when I was done and they just
said cool and then they ran off that's
it so I kind of thought I just spent a
Saturday painting on an American Girl
doll I could have made other choices and
bid a week later a week later Whitten
lucía's she's my older daughter she's 11
now this is several years ago I went
into her room and she had these drawings
in her room where she set up her stuffed
animals and she was drawing their
portrait and and it was like it like if
you have ever had that moment where
you're so surprised like a rush of hot
you know wind goes through your body and
and I realized that that American girl
painting was probably one of the most
important pieces of artwork I would have
ever made in my life
and and watching her do that and feeling
like I played a role in affecting her on
and and actually it just boils down to
the idea that watching your kids go off
and find success is actually more
important than me or a parent
we're meant or finding their own success
and that is we had that early on I had
this experience early on and that's kind
of the thing with the movie we've been
chasing the long game of how I see
McQueen's arc in this movie thank you
very much for being here
I appreciate your your time haven't